bonjour pierre guerlain merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france comment est-ce qu'il faut
interpréter ces manifestations de masse
pro trump preuve que la société
américaine est plus que jamais divisée
alors faut quand même relativiser il y
avait entre 20 à 30000 personnes alors
que le parti république annonçait qu'il
y aura un million
donc il y a des partisans de tom qui ont
défilé dans les rues de washington
pas très nombreux mais effectivement la
société américaine est complètement du
bizet et il ya l'image qui quand même à
porte c'est donc il ya ces personnes au
tram qui manifestent rome passe dans sa
voiture blindée ne descend pas fait un
signe de la main pour aller jouer au
golf
c'est tout à fait typique de gens qui
appartiennent à classe dirigeante qui
actionne des gens qui sont souvent des
clubs défavorisés pour voter pour eux
mais qui ne sont pas qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas mais mon quand vous
avez un leader démocratique comme lula
au brésil
quand il fait campagne il au milieu des
gens il est clair que tom c'est
quelqu'un qui est isolé mais qui veut
actionner des gens défavorisés pour
avoir leur voix c'est tout et
effectivement et le la triche qui existe
des d'avenir principalement eu triche
organisée depuis d'aider des années par
les républicains qui raillent des
électeurs des listes électorales les
empêche d'aller voter et aujourd'hui
l'accusation est totalement clownesque
puisqu'en fait
les républicains accusent les autres de
faire ce que eux mêmes font depuis des
années justement donald trump conteste
le recomptage des voix notamment en
géorgie quelles suites judiciaires pour
le président sortant à quoi est-ce qu'il
faut s'attendre on sait que le 14
décembre il ya le collège électoral qui
se réunit pour valider le 46e président
des états unis avec les sept suites
judiciaires est ce qu'on peut s'attendre
à des bouleversements
c'est très peu probable alors il faut
toujours faire attention parce que les
surprises arrivent les unes après les
autres aux états unis mais déjà il ya un
certain nombre de deux de quoi quand tu
es perdu devant les tribunaux par
l'administration de femmes et dans le
cas le plus favorable aux craintes même
s'il arrivait à invalider les élections
à georgi de toute façon byden aurait
suffisamment de voir au collège
électoral pour gagner sans la géorgie
donc cette voie là est peu probable
et ce qui est important de noter quand
même c'est que 3 est lâché par une
partie du monde de la finance il est
lâché pas au ku c'est à dire bravo tu
m'as doc il est lâché aussi par les
militaires il ya un militaire qui a dit
que en syrie le démenti ou président sur
le nombre de troupes américaines en
syrie
donc il n'a pas de soutien très fort
parmi les classes dirigeantes
c'est un baroud d'honneur ou évidemment
c'est la stratégie du chaos il mais il
essaie de mettre le chaos dans les rues
de tromper le monde avec des airs vous
parler de cas où on a vu des
échauffourées à la nuit dernière entre
les pro et les anti trust parce qu'un
risque d' escalade des violences
urbaines est possible alors
effectivement puisque comme s'appuie sur
des groupes d'extrême droite les play
boys et que la stratégie du désordre
dans les rues peut lui être favorable il
y à 7
il ya cette tentation mais on peut
penser que la motivation principale
cette fois encore c'est que chuck ne
veut pas perdre il risque disons les
choses clairement il risque la prison
d'ain qu'il ne sera plus président parce
qu'il a énormément de procès dont il
essaye de faire diversion
on peut penser que
ça ne marchera pas comment est ce que
joe biden lui prépare la transition est
ce que c'est possible pour lui de
commencer à travailler vraiment alors
joe biden préparer la transition
alors il faut quand même dire que baydan
offre des gens qui sont liées au secteur
de l'armement aux donateurs du parti
démocrate
il n'est pas quelqu'un de gauche face à
quelqu'un d'extrême droite il n'a
effectivement pas encore accès aux
renseignements des services de
renseignement au moins tout au moins
officiellement
et effectivement ça gêne ça gêne la
transition qui doit avoir lieu le 20
janvier et d'ici le 20 janvier
on peut penser que y'aura la décision du
collège électoral que les remises en
cause des résultats d'élection seront
beaucoup plus difficiles et que tout
homme devra quand même se soumettre
on sait que healy hamac en po1 qui est
arrivée en europe il effectue une
tournée européenne il rencontre
d'ailleurs demain emmanuel macron que
peuvent se dire les deux hommes
transition vraiment où est ce que le
secrétaire d'état américain actuel va
dire à emmanuel macron on va encore
travailler ensemble pour ces quatre
prochaines années alors je pense que
tous les dirigeants qui rendent compte
eux pompéo savent très bien que après le
20 janvier il y aura un autre une autre
administration mais il ya eu un article
dans le monde et aussi dans le yachting
robitaille qui mettaient en garde contre
les possibilités de chaos au niveau
international et il n'est pas impossible
que toi nous soit déligitimer aux états
unis mais cherche à avoir une action
militaire important est ce que disent
un certain nombre d'observateurs dont
robotman c'est que c'est l'iran qui
serait visé par une intervention
américaine sans que ce qui est
impossible sur le plan intérieur est
peut-être possible sur le plan extérieur
merci pierre galand d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur émérite de
civilisation à l'université paris ouest
nanterre paris 10